- I reacted to "South Park"
medical scenes last year
and you liked it so much,
you came out to my tour
and begged for more.
- I need more "South Park" from you, dude.
- Or at least one of you did.
Huge thank you to ShipStation
for sponsoring this video, peewoop!
- Okay Kenny, I bet you $100
you can't light a fart on fire.
(Kenny mumbles)
(match strikes)
(fart toots)
(Kenny laughs)
(Kenny screams)
- Holy shit, dude!
- He didn't just light a fart on fire.
Lart a fart on fire.
Light a fart on fire.
He actually lit himself on fire.
(nurse chatter)
- [Surgeon] Load that IV with
70 CC's of sodium penathol.
- Why is he bleeding profusely?
Yeah, you have skin damage
and some blood loss,
but you're not just shooting out,
gushing out blood.
- Vacuum.
Try to untangle his trachea and esophagus.
- Untangle his trachea and esophagus.
The trachea being your windpipe,
your esophagus being your food pipe,
like why are they tangled?
- [Nurse 1] Watch his liver.
- [Nurse 2] I'll get it.
- Ah!
- This looks like my virtual simulator.
This is why you go to medical school.
You throw the intestines away.
- [Nurse 1] Doctor, his heart stopped.
- So you gotta do chest compressions,
chest compressions, chest compressions!
- We need to zap this quick.
- No, you don't gotta zap it.
You gotta squeeze it.
He's putting it in the microwave.
Jesus.
- Who's making a potato?
- Is that George Clooney?
- [Surgeon] Kenny. Kenny, can you hear me?
- [Kenny] Holy shit dude.
- How are you feeling, son?
- [Kenny] Not so good.
- Great. Son, I have some bad news.
We accidentally replaced your
heart with a baked potato.
You have about three seconds to live.
- [Kenny] What?
- So he wouldn't wake up
is what you're saying.
In all reality,
burning yourself is quite dangerous
because it causes you to lose fluids.
Because skin prevents fluid loss.
And you need to carefully manage,
not just fluids but electrolyte balance
in patients who have severe burns.
- What is a proctologist, Chef?
- He's a doctor that specializes
in your asshole, children.
- We've moved away from
using the term proctologist
to now discussing that
specialty as colorectal surgery.
Some people confuse a GI
doctor and colorectal surgeon.
They both focus on the GI tract.
Colorectal surgeon is a surgical field
that mainly focuses on the
anus, rectum, and intestines.
Where the GI doctor
focuses on the usually
mostly non-surgical approach
of the entire GI tract
from the mouth to anus.
There are both colorectal surgeons
and GI doctors who perform colonoscopies.
Usually though what happens is
the GI doctor performs the colonoscopy
and if they find something
that needs removal,
they then send them to
a colorectal surgeon.
That's usually what happens.
- What seems to be the problem?
- We just want you to take a look
and tell us if you see anything abnormal.
- Other than it's monstrous size.
- Well, proctologists also
don't look at buttocks,
so they wouldn't tell you
anything about your glutes.
- Well, the prostate seems to be normal.
No swelling of the hormonal gland.
(Cartman grunts)
Wait, what's this?
(doctor screams)
- Okay, alien satellite dish
not usually found in rectums.
2022, line, Doctor Mike.
(upbeat music)
- You know that feeling
when you take a huge dump?
Awesome.
- Well, doctor?
- I've never quite seen this before.
Perhaps he just needs
some hemorrhoid cream.
- Hemorrhoid cream is usually focused on
dealing with inflammation.
So there's some kind of
steroidal component to the cream.
There's also pain relief component,
sometimes like lidocaine or benzocaine.
- Hello everyone,
my name is John Garner
and I'm a nutrition advisor from the USDA.
There's been a lot of
confusion about gluten lately.
- There's also been a lot of confusion
because of your ridiculous food
pyramids that make no sense.
- People saying that gluten
is the cause of cancer.
Gluten should be avoided.
Gluten can make your dick fly off.
But let's set the record straight.
- Make your dick fly off?
- So what is gluten?
- Gluten is the protein
component found within wheat.
- Gluten is the protein found in flour
when you take all the starch away.
Not a bio weapon, just
harmless flower protein.
- Then eat it.
- Excuse me.
- If it's not dangerous
then eat that pure
concentrated gluten, okay.
- All right.
(Doctor shrieks)
(crowd screams)
- Ah! Ah!
- Do I see a robot? What is this?
- Oh, you see that? His dick's flying off.
- We did have a period in time
where people were
deathly afraid of gluten.
There was a good reason for
some people to avoid gluten.
Those who have celiac disease,
which is a true autoimmune disease
that when you're intestines
are exposed to gluten,
your body starts to have
an autoimmune reaction
where it starts attacking the intestines.
So basically your
intestines in order to have
more surface area for better absorption
have these little
projections called villi.
And these villi,
actually are the ones that
make contact with gluten,
present them to the body,
and then your body starts attacking
these projections called villi,
therefore you get blunting of the villi
and they get short,
which can lead to mal absorption,
lack of certain nutrients and vitamins,
diarrhea, bloating, pain, et cetera.
And there are some
situations where you have
non celiac wheat sensitivity,
where eating wheat can actually
give you an upset stomach.
But it's not an autoimmune
disease like celiac disease.
That's why when you go to a restaurant
some people say like,
"Oh, I prefer to avoid
gluten based product,"
is one thing.
But for your person with celiac disease,
you wanna avoid having foods prepared
in a facility where gluten is present.
- There's hot dog buns
in that cupboard, Sharon.
- Hey dad, I need to talk to you
about this party we're having.
- Oh my god, the Wheat Thins!
- [Sharon] And the Triscuits too, Randy.
- Wait, wait. I might need those.
- This stuff will make
your dick fly off, Stan.
- The thing that surprised me the most,
'cause there was a period of time
where I went gluten free was
soy sauce has gluten in it.
- What about ice cream?
- I dunno. Look at the ingredients!
- It sometimes uses a thickening agent.
- Heavy cream, sugar, chocolate syrup.
No ice cream's good for you.
- Ice cream's good for you.
- All right, that's all of it.
- You sure? All right, you got those?
- I can get both of these, yeah.
- Come on.
- What's going on?
(ominous music)
- Well, that's just a beer.
- Oh Jesus.
- Beer is all wheat, dad.
- Shut up! Beer's bad for you?
- We're gonna need you
to come with us, sir.
Don't touch me.
- Look, I'm okay.
You wanna see my dick?
- We just need you to be
in quarantine for a while
until everyone figures
out what's going on.
- How'd you get exposed?
Bagels?
Gravy?
- Beer. I didn't know it had gluten.
- There's always something.
For me it was the soy sauce.
(bell dings)
- Sir, we've got a boy on the hotline
that says he might know something.
- Who is this?
- My name isn't important.
What matters is that
the answer is in the pyramid.
- We built the pyramid a long time ago
to illustrate how much people should eat
of the four basic food groups.
- And it was (expletive)
pyramid guidance ever.
- It's upside down.
- What?
(computer beeps)
- Sir, we've gotta match.
- Nutrition is stabilizing.
- We've got a well-balanced vaccine, sir.
(employees cheer)
- Get the president on the phone.
Tell him to have some
steak with his butter.
- Please don't do that.
The saturated fat is out of control.
Let me quickly tell you about ShipStation,
the leading web-based order management
and shipping software.
It's designed to make
retailers' lives easier
by processing, fulfilling,
and shipping eCommerce
orders more efficiently.
I know the hassle of
running an online business.
I've been shipping out merch
for the better part of a year.
So I understand the value
of having the right tools
before you get started.
Imagine if I started selling merch
before having solid management
and shipping infrastructures in place.
I'd be buried in orders
and unable to grow my business.
Thanks to ShipStation,
you can focus on growth from day one,
as they eliminate the headaches that come
with printing labels, handling orders,
across multiple platforms
like Amazon, Etsy, eBay,
even your own website.
Get the same discounted shipping rates
as Fortune 500 companies.
Whether you're sending
a stack or a truck full.
130,000 companies have grown their
e-commerce business with them
and 98% of companies that
use them for one year
become customers for life.
Ship more and grow more with ShipStation.
Go to shipstation.com/doctormike.
Remember doctor is spelled out
and if you sign up today
you're gonna get a 60 day free trial.
Start today and get set up
before the biggest shipping
season of the year.
That's two months free.
All right, let's get back
to some "South Park."
- Hello, boys.
Your mommy has a bacterial
infection called c-diff.
- Oh, that's problematic.
Clostridium difficile
is the type of bacteria
that can live in the gut,
but then once it multiplies
and it becomes to the infectious level,
it creates foul smelling,
heavy watery, mucusy diarrhea.
So much so that you could transfer it
to other people through contact.
We actually in hospitals,
when a patient tests positive for c-diff,
put them on contact precautions
where in order to walk into the room,
you have to glove up, gown up,
and then wash your hands with soap
and water before and after.
- All of us have trillions
of microscopic critters
that grow on and inside our bodies.
- And some of them actually
help us with digestion.
- We can't use antibiotics
because that will kill
all the good bacteria too.
- Well, that's not true.
We absolutely have
antibiotics that we can use.
In fact, one of the
common antibiotics we use
is one called vancomycin,
is a very potent antibiotic
that we usually use
through IV methods
because it is not well absorbed
when you're taking it orally.
But now imagine if you have an
infection in your intestines
and you want the medication to stay there,
then taking a medicine
that is not well absorbed
actually is beneficial,
hence why we use vancomycin
in these types of infections.
- So what can you do for her?
- We need to take a
healthy person's microbiome
and start to grow it inside your mother.
We do this with a fecal transplant.
We'll get a donor's feces,
mix it with water,
and put it up your mom's anus.
- We actually do do fecal transplants.
That actually has really
good high rates of clearance
of the infection.
I recently saw there were
some medications being tested
where they actually freeze dried
some of that poop into capsules
and then you take it
and then it opens up in your intestines
and it serves the same purpose.
- [Sam] You swallow it.
- Yeah, but it's in capsules.
Cause if you don't take it by mouth,
the only other way to do it
is through a colonoscopy.
- Parents, I called you all together
because I think you
might be making a mistake
putting your children on Ritalin.
- But our kids have attention
deficit disorder, Chef.
They can't pay attention
to school without it.
- There's this doctor
in Northern California
who is doing really amazing
things with kids who have ADD.
I want you to watch this tape.
- For attention deficit
hyperactivity disorder,
Ritalin is a medication
that is prescribed.
It's similar in nature to Adderall,
although it's a different
medication inside.
In Adderall you have like an
amphetamine based prescription
whereas in Ritalin it's methylphenidate.
What's different is the time of onset.
So in Ritalin the peak comes sooner
than it does on Adderall.
Therefore it lasts for a
shorter period of time.
- This treatment is fast and effective
and doesn't use harmful drugs.
Watch closely as I apply
treatment to the first child.
- By the way, there are legitimate,
non-pharmacological behavioral
options for children
and adults who are diagnosed with ADHD.
- Sit down and study!
(children chatter)
- Now I laugh at this
'cause it's "South Park,"
but in reality this is
kind of mean spirited
because patients who have true ADHD,
it's not as simple as just, sit still.
Their mind is literally racing
and it's not a discipline issue.
It's a biological issue.
And at the same time I will say,
there are parents and children,
mostly parents that request
medications for their children
when it's probably a lack of discipline
that is the issue.
Which one would I say
is a greater problem?
I think it's worse when
you poke fun at people
who actually need the medicine
and would benefit from it.
But it's more problematic to society
when you put children on
medicine that they don't need.
- What do you think?
I can have Dr. Shay come to
South Park for a small fee.
- That video had pretty colors.
- It sure did.
- Dammit!
Have you all been taking
your children's Ritalin too?
- [All] Yes.
- Well adults have ADHD too.
And it's not necessarily runs in families,
but there is a potential
genetic component there.
- Professor Chaos cannot be stopped.
- Oh, yeah. Kenny, use your ninja star.
- Here, try this Professor Chaos.
(adventure music)
- Oh, ninja star to the eye.
(Butters screams)
Don't pull it out. Seek help immediately.
- Just stay still Butters.
- Oh no.
- Ah.
Ah.
- Just why would you do this?
(Butters screams)
- Stop dude, you're
gonna scramble his brain!
- You're not gonna scramble his brain.
You're gonna cause him to bleed out.
- You guys can't fix my eyeball.
You have to take me to the hospital.
- Yes, please.
- We need a doctor but we
can't go to the hospital.
- And you need a very specific doctor.
'Cause if you bring me,
I ain't doing smack.
- Wait, wait, what about the veterinarian?
- Dr. Shaffy?
- He's really old and and going blind.
- So if we make Butters
up to look like a dog.
- Oh, no.
(Butters cries)
- Hand me the modeling glue.
We need more fur over here.
- This reminds me of those mobster movies
where they can't go to see a doctor,
so they go to the local
vet to pull out the bullet.
(Butters moans)
- Oh my god, what the?
Doctor, doctor!
- Jesus Christ.
(Butters moans)
What kind of sick bastard
would do this to a dog?
Poor little pup.
(Butters moans and barks)
- Can you help him doctor?
- I'm afraid I wouldn't know how.
Unfortunately for this little
fella, I'm a people doctor.
Best we call the animal shelter.
- Right away.
- Oh my god, I can't even react to this
'cause there's nothing I can say.
I ain't doing smack.
- Yeah, you like that?
Woo, man!
- Aw, lord!
(breakdance music)
- Ooh, he is getting served.
(country music)
- Randy.
- Why is again,
the stupid chart looks
like he's in a recession
in the stock market.
Like what are we looking at.
And what are the vitals and
bar graphs above his bed?
- He got served.
Worst I've ever seen.
- His dancing was so fast
I couldn't do anything.
His moves were so original, so inventive.
- Why does he need nasal
cannula oxygenation for that?
- He mostly got served here and here.
But the worst serving was
here in the pelvis region.
The road to recovery will be a long one.
- What is the injury?
Is it a fracture?
- Do you know what happened
to me this morning, Stan?
This morning I woke up and
felt a sharp pain in my ass.
I felt down there and and
found this big sore lump.
- Was it a pimple?
Was it a hemorrhoid?
Which part of your are we talking about?
- I have a hemorrhoid.
And Cartman has his own theme park.
- That's not the end of the world.
A lot of times hemorrhoids happen
from people spending a
lot of time on toilets.
A lot of time it's from cell phone use.
People just hang out for
a long period of time.
Bearing down a lot when
having bowel movements,
usually, as a result of
constipation that can happen.
So increasing fiber is really smart.
- What's that?
- It's my seat ring.
I have to sit on it
because of my hemorrhoid.
- That seat ring not only
helps with hemorrhoids,
but also coccydynia.
- Come on, dude.
- Oh go, I popped it!
Oh, it hurts!
- What the hell are you doing?
- Oh, crap.
- Oh god, get me off of here.
- A bleeding hemorrhoid
that has thrombosed
bleeds very heavily.
- Stan, I have to go home!
I need my cream!
- It's not just cream.
A lot of times it might
need surgical intervention.
When I say surgical intervention,
it could be something as
simple as a banding procedure
where we literally put a
type bandaid over the area
and it chokes it out of its blood supply.
And as a result, it ends up falling off.
- I'm sorry. Your son appears
to be losing the battle.
- What is he septic?
- I'm afraid that the hemorrhoid
has spread to his lungs.
- What? It's not a cancer.
In fact, a hemorrhoid
is just a blood vessel
that has expanded.
Usually, to the point where
it can't shrink back down.
If it got infected, it's
now infected and expanded.
Not something that's contagious.
- Normally the body would
fight the infection,
but he's just given up on life.
- But then are you saying-
- There's nothing more I can do.
Little fella's just lost his will to live.
- You could just give him antibiotic
and cheer him up.
But I will say mindset
is an important factor
in whether or not someone gets better
and how fast they get better.
Those who have a positive
optimistic outlook
do tend to fare better.
Goes hand in hand with
the placebo studies.
And the sugar pill
people, 30% of the time,
experience the same effects as the ones
who got the real medication.
- Yeah, that's a pretty
bad lice problem there.
Good thing they pulled you outta school.
- Well, actually, lice,
people think lives in dirty hair.
But the reality is cleaner hair
makes it easier to transfer lice
and also for the lice to move
around and get comfortable.
Maximal killing power.
- I love the rain.
(lice laughs)
(ominous music)
- These are cute lice.
- What is that?
(ominous music)
(lice screams)
- You know you never think
about things like that.
(lice scream)
I feel bad for lice now.
My sympathy goes up for lice.
Rip lice.
Did you know I performed
surgery virtually?
Surgeon simulator and virtual reality,
click here to check that out.
And don't forget to visit
shipstation.com/doctormike
to begin your 60 day free trial.
As always, stay happy and healthy.
(upbeat music)